[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le chemin de l'école nous avions 12
ou 13 ans cheveux blonds et tête folle
nous parlions comme les
grands nous avions la tête
pleine de jolis
projets moi j'avais pour Madeline un
tendre
secret dites-moi ce qui m'entraîne
dites-moi d'où vient le vent où sons ce
que l'on aime dites-moi ce qui m'attend
où sons ce que l'on aime dites-moi ce
qui
m'attend sur le chemin de la vie nous
nous sommes
séparer chacun songe sa partie j'ai
dépensé sans
[Musique]
compter les amis l'argent les filles et
puis mes 20 ans je n'ai pour toute
famille qu'un petit
enfant
dites-moi ce qui
m'entraîne dites-moi d'où vient le vent
où sen va
ce que l'on aime dites-moi ce qui
m'attend
ù sbrons ce que l'on aime dites-moi ce
qui
m'attend sur le chemin de l'école quand
j'irai
t'accompagner je t'en donne ma parole je
saurai te
protéger je t'offrirai des voyages une
jolie
maison je
t'apprendrai le langage des quatre
[Musique]
saisons
dites-moi ce qui
m'entraîne dites-moi d'où vient le vent
où sen Bont ce que l'on aime dites-moi
ce qui m'attend nous sons ce que l'on
aim dites-moi ce qui
[Musique]
maant
I